[Música]
y
cuando estaba en el tercer año de la
residencia de cirugía general me
atravesó un proceso de cambio y de
transformación básicamente fue una
crisis personal es de vida y profesional
en ese momento como buen médico y
teniendo todos los conocimientos en mi
mente lo diagnóstica como síndrome de
burnout o síndrome del trabajador
quemado
básicamente es un estrés crónico que se
produce por el trabajo y el estilo de
vida que llevamos día a día hoy lo
comparo con la experiencia del ave fénix
en ese momento me sentía realmente
cansado agotado física y mentalmente
desmotivado emocionalmente sin ganas de
levantarme a la mañana para ir a
trabajar cuando llegaba al trabajo no
había comido no había desayunado pasado
a la jornada laboral había tomado muy
poca agua
me sentía todo el día cansado queriendo
estar durmiendo queriendo estar siempre
en otro lugar que en el que estaba
me sentía desconectado de mis padres de
mis compañeros y sobre todo y lo peor de
todo perdiendo la compasión y la empatía
con los pacientes en ese momento me
sentí como un caballo con ojeras que
solo puede mirar hacia adelante más bien
como un burro como un asno con una carga
pesada en el lomo y con la intención
siempre llegar esa zanahoria por delante
que si alguna vez la alcancé nunca tuvo
el sabor que creía que iba a tener
en ese momento decidí tomar conciencia y
protagonismo de mi vida y el día a día y
cuando me levantaba trata de acordarme
que había soñado
y lo anotaba y cuando estaba despertando
me me hacía consciente que me estaba
despertando y como me está despertando
si estaba cansado se había dormido bien
se había dormido mal se había dormido un
poco si nos faltaban horas de sueño
tomar conciencia que estaba comiendo
apenas me levantaba que estaba tomando
la cabeza en seguida en todo lo que
tenía que hacer en todo lo que había
quedado pendiente el día anterior de la
semana anterior del año anterior de los
meses anteriores y con todo lo que tenía
que hacer ese día y mañana y pasado y
empecé a tomar conciencia real de que no
estaba en el momento presente no estaba
ahora que es el verdadero momento que
uno tiene para empezar a hacer los
cambios en el día a día en ese momento
hubieron dos herramientas que me
ayudaron de manera fundamental que en su
momento las encontré muy simples y muy
sencillas de realizar pero que a medida
que empecé a interiorizarme eran
difíciles de realizar porque requerían
de mi responsabilidad
y mi conciencia diaria de estar presente
para realizar las una son las
meditaciones y las respiraciones
conscientes la otra es la alimentación
las meditaciones y las respiraciones
conscientes las pude
y experimentar y conocerlas en un viaje
que realizó a eeuu trabajando como
cirujano pero me puse en contacto en la
costa oeste con toda una filosofía
oriental que en ese sector entró hace
mucho tiempo y la empecé a experimentar
y empecé a encontrar que esa herramienta
que durante los años de la carrera y
durante la formación en la residencia y
después los años de profesión no me
habían enseñado que había estudios
científicos que avalaban por ejemplo
para finales del año 2009 ya existían
millones de citas bibliográficas con
referencias a las meditaciones y 150
estudios dobles ciegos randomizados con
todo el aval científico que demuestran
los estudios que esos estudios
demuestran los beneficios en la salud
tanto física y mental
el otro concepto importante la
alimentación la base que tenemos en el
día a día lo que nos nutre y lo que nos
da la energía para el día a día
tampoco me han enseñado a comer no sabía
cómo comer cuando quise ser consciente
de eso me di cuenta de que no tenía las
herramientas y también encontré estudios
científicos que hoy le avalan y que
demuestran los beneficios con cambios
muy simples en los estilos de vida y
esas dos herramientas me ayudaron a
generar la conexión que había perdido
que hoy la medicina perdió hoy la
medicina occidental tiene una visión
fragmentada del proceso de la salud de
la enfermedad
no relaciona la emoción con el plano
físico no relaciona una enfermedad
física con un síntoma quizás no en el
mismo momento pero en el transcurso del
tiempo y puede ver como los pensamientos
están conectados con una emoción cuando
pensamos en algo enseguida tenemos una
emoción y como esa emoción después tiene
una manifestación física y haciendo el
camino inverso empecé a ver que esa
visión fragmentada y dirigida hacia la
enfermedad de la medicina hoy occidental
queda corta es una visión corta y creo
que hoy es momento de empezar a integrar
las medicinas oriente-occidente es el
mismo mundo y son dos sabidurías muy
importantes y distintas pero
complementarias ese es mi mensaje y de
eso mi charla de volver ahora acá al
momento presente ser conscientes de que
nos está pasando por el cuerpo que nos
está pasando por la mente que son esos
pensamientos recurrentes que me duele y
no callarlo
o dejarlo de lado o taparlo con un
analgésico por ejemplo cosas muy
sencillas porque eso tiene un trasfondo
muy profundo en la vida y cuando uno
empieza a poder tener eso y poder palpar
lo empieza a descubrir otra dimensión de
la persona y de la salud de la
enfermedad
yo lo relaciono con la experiencia del
ave fénix porque cada 500 años
cumpliendo un ciclo de vida esta vez se
incinera en incienso mirra canela
sanando y purificando parte de su cuerpo
y renace más vital más fuerte trayendo
un nuevo mensaje fraternal de esperanza
y de buenaventura anza gracias
[Aplausos]